one of the most
i think one of the most powerful
qualities of music
is is its capacity to
dramatize
the field of awareness
of the present moment so at any
at any moment you can choose
to put on a song that can quickly turn
the ordinary and the quotidian into the
dramatic
and the deeply meaningful and resonating
and what i love about that
is that
it lends a playfulness a creative
potential in a creative possibility
space
for playfulness in every moment that we
can
with a kind of musical sorcery
we can
very quickly take the drab and the
quotidian and re-enchant it we can make
of our lives theater we can make of our
lives drama we can make of our moments
dramaticism dramatic
magic and and it's just a great
thing to know it's a great thing to
remember because
it it it opens up a
kaleidoscopic amount of possibility in
every moment of creative possibility in
every moment of creative play and
imagination in every moment that every
moment can be appropriated
and
and
and brought into a kind of
gamification and dramatization that we
can make of ordinary moments theater
that we can make of ordinary moment
of ordinary moments drama and infuse
deep meaningfulness and make ourselves
engaged with life again by by by by
living dramatically and living like it
matters and deploying the right music
the right song the right drama it also
means stewardship of internal life
stewardship of one's world stewardship
of one's field of awareness i mean the
the poverty i think of boredom the
poverty of of of the drab and the
quotidian is that it's a it's a
it's a false conclusion it's a false
truth about any moment oh this is boring
oh i'm so jaded oh it's so boring i'm so
numb to it all but that's like such
such a failure of the imagination such a
failure of our agency such a failure of
our sorcery of our capacity to hit play
of the possibility space that exists at
the doorstep of every moment if we just
had the the wherewithal and creative
discipline courage and and if we just
remembered that we can just say hey put
on this song it'll fix things
take this ordinary moment full of full
of full of boredom and and and gnawing
neuroticism and lend its song lend it
drama lend it theater lend it magic
lend it
aesthetic arrest
make the world miraculous once more
through the power of your art direction
your creative and linguistic choices
they govern your fate they shape your
world they author your theater
and to miss out on this possibility is
is such a
it's such a mistake
and i hope you don't make it
so that's it
free the free free the free brave
reckless gods that live inside of you
and deploy
creativity and music and make of your
life a magnificent
work of art
there's a great line
in the documentary called flight from
death that ends
with the following conclusion
life exists in individual moments and it
is up to us to make sure those moments
are vital
interconnected and grand
to make a masterpiece out of our lives
one that we would willingly live again
and again for all of eternity
this
is what we can strive for
so that's it
that's it
that's it